au mois d'août sur la route du retour
des vacances syriza passe par hasard
dans ce village de serre dont il est
chaud et soif et on s'arrêter boire un
verre ici et de là on a vu que la
boucherie étaient fermés on a été voir
la boulangère à côté on a rappelé la
mairie trois quatre jours après et ce à
son plancher comme ça un mail et
quelques coups de téléphone plus tard le
couple originaire de région parisienne
signe le bail thierry boucher depuis
plus de 40 ans reprend du service dans
cette commune de 1000 habitants
pour le plus grand bonheur du maire on a
refait les travaux au niveau du logement
pour qu'il soit quand même dans de
bonnes conditions
voilà et non non ça a été vite et tant
mieux tant mieux tous les jours depuis
un mois de nouveaux clients passent la
porte de la boucherie des habitants de
cerdon et des villages alentour même
d'aider des gens c'est rigolo qui ne
font que passer se rendent compte qu'il
ya de nouveau une boucherie viennent
tester et reviennent après c'est super
d'avoir une boucherie dans le village
une supérette de boulanger on a vraiment
de la chance pour un village qui est pas
très grand mais qui vit pour lydie la
boulangère avoir un commerce e vide à
côté de sa boutique n'était pas de bonne
augure
les habitants obligés d'aller ailleurs
pour acheter leur viande ne s'arrêtait
plus dans sa boulangerie on n'avait
qu'une le fait qu'ils ouvrent ça fait
nous 27 ans qu'on ait installé à faire
don donc l'un vraiment besoin d'avoir un
ensemble commercial pour être un bourg
dynamique et puis que les gens en laye
pas dans les grandes surfaces et qui
reviennent chez des petits pour faire
vivre nos campagnes quoi tous les
commerçants de la place sont à même
souhait pour 2021 voir se lever le
rideau du bureau de tabac la mairie
cherche un repreneur pour continuer
d'attirer des habitants et de faire
vivre pour de cerdon